the gyro can experience so this isn't
Florida you can get away with anything
there you used to be able to other
tighten it down on Florida thank God
[ __ ] Florida 2019 it took you this long
well Florida was the place where the
pain pill mills existed will have the
management centers the pain management
centers right next to an oxycontin store
dude so you go to the doctor it's a yeah
my back's killing me doctors like you
need pain pills know that I do need pain
pills this is right a piece of paper and
then you would literally go to the next
door over and it was the building
connected to them that sells the pain
pills they'd have it in the same spot
sometimes that's like cocaine country -
right yeah every so [ __ ] high in
Florida
oh dude Florida's crazy it's crazy it's
got a history of high I feel like the
the chaos of the 80s of all the cocaine
is burned into the psyche of the
landmass yeah and then the alligators
moved in and there's even more reptilian
more reptilian when I was a kid I lived
there I lived in Israel I lived in
Gainesville yeah Gaines North Florida
right North I don't know if it's nor is
it North sort of this minute medallist
but America I mean we were around
alligators but they were endangered back
then so they would tell me good yeah
yeah they thought of them is in danger
people are so silly they're like we have
to protect these [ __ ] monsters that
are around us we have and when I was
there
some ladies poodle got snatched I think
it was a pool it was a small dog got
snatched by an alligator while I was
there and uh yeah yeah I didn't see it
happen but I came like after it happened
and people were all freaked out and they
were telling you to stop feeding the
marshmallows we would feed alligators
marshmallow and they keep coming back
well the thing is they would they like
the marshmallows like so you knew if you
through the marshmallows alligator to
come up and eat it and they got used to
eating marshmallows and then there was
science they said don't have the
alligators eat marshmallows because it's
apparently bad for the digestive system
and bla bla bla bla bla [ __ ] everywhere
your mother can heat a whole dog with a
collar on yeah I mean it's not just the
dog's collar it's swallowing that collar
it's gonna [ __ ] out that metal buckle uh
you you really think I'm marshmallows
gonna start so this attitude that they
had that
wanted to bring back the alligator it
was a good thing because you know they
really were on the verge of extinction
but then it became the opposite so now
I'll Gators everywhere so now like
alligators people find him in their
house yeah they find them in their pool
like they're snatching people up like
rats in New York they're everywhere and
they're so did you see that one that was
really recently filmed walking across a
golf course no it is a dinosaur really
15 feet long I do love the Gator though
yeah really it's an awesome animal see
if you could find the video the video of
the giant alligator they and they said
by the way that this alligator is
probably somewhere in the neighborhood
of 80 years old
yeah he's 80 years old zero 80 years
that's a 8 year old alligator god he
never experienced any kind of racism or
Jim Crow laws they just yeah walking
through that machine yeah yeah good for
them but when you here it is look at
this oh [ __ ] you were lying oh my god
he's 80 years old it's an 80 year old
alligator he's moving kind of fresh
they'd say the ones that are really big
when they get to be that like 15 foot
length yeah because a lot of those are
really old
56 no arthritis I mean guy friend shot
one and it was more than 80 years old
shoutout to John Dudley I think your
Eddie's a dinosaur is a goddamn lie that
means that is rewind that again because
we're both super high I mean that is
what does he even do imagine seeing that
Brian Moses yeah or in your yard you're
chilling hanging out on your phone got
your feet up and you see that walking
across your yard
yeah I got you get the [ __ ] out of
Florida like how close is that to me
what the [ __ ] I mean that's it's super
dope look I mean look at that thing yeah
he's got a scab there too how much you
think that weighs
let's go half a ton 500 pound I think it
sounds easy
did you see the guys fishing and the one
I am he's reeling a big-ass fish and the
Gator once it starts chasing on land and
these guys like get the [ __ ] out of the
way
oh my god it's a thousand-pound gat egg
but it's big that's a lot of church
shoes it's so big
a lot of church shoes but these things
they live amongst us and they eat dogs
yeah and they deer and everything else
they can get their hands they have to
eat a lot of food to maintain that
[ __ ] bad is it so the guy oh my god
somebody's always opposed them the
Gators chasing them holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
whoa coed jelly is 480 do they move
quick they move don't who knows how old
that one is that could be a younger one
oh he's stealing this dude's fish yeah
keep the fish Wow
get robbed forest fish yeah you just got
Jack knock it down yeah I was gonna say
that doesn't look like an alligator
that's a crocodile what's the difference
crocodiles have like a pointy or snout
and they're way more aggressive okay so
don't [ __ ] with a croc alligators are
better yeah oh my god they're better
okay this is many crocodiles there are
alligators in Florida way more people to
be getting jacked Oh so croc is uh-oh
Crocs will [ __ ] everybody up Crocs do
not discriminate
they get water buffalos people they
don't the [ __ ] their real aggressive -
there was this one video of um they had
like an alligator farm and they were
raising alligators and then they had one
crocodile and so when they came time to
feeding the one crocodiles like bits
down sit the [ __ ] down
climbing on top of these roosters at him
feel like yeah but he was on the top of
all the alligators [ __ ] off [ __ ] off of
here it just took control and was
getting the food no well crying or a
crocodile either get an alligator that's
a good question they hate each other
do they really want a caiman where's it
came in from that's across about but
it's a very small crocodile
okay Caymans are small they live in the
Amazon have you eaten crocodile
no or Gator yeah how's it I was I had I
had a place it was like a [ __ ] TGI
Fridays type joint it wasn't the best
it wasn't TGI Fridays but you know it
was like one Applebee's type place right
like a chain yeah that's data and it
wasn't like fresh but apparently when
you get it fresh like right off the
Gator it's supposed to be really good
there's like any meat could be like that
you know doing even Rhett yeah but the
alligator thing is like oh did you eat
Gator
yeah dude we went crazy what a weekend
No
[Applause]